okay welcome back we have a familiar
face here Jill Bork from rushed X which
went through our first incubator class
we now call it an accelerator of those
seven companies one of them got acquired
it's worked out really well for us
that was Sony's company requested and
red tricycle stole I'm strong I'm strong
and rushed extol it's still in the game
still still get in the game and growing
good so we're in a new phase great tell
us so well tell me what Rush Dix is okay
yeah so rush tix is a subscription-based
live entertainment platform Netflix for
live events exactly and we were out
fundraising a year ago yep and we got a
real mess response okay from VCS got it
they said you don't have enough traction
and we don't think this market is big
enough and at that time you're doing
what 10k a month yeah or they're like
eight nine so that makes sense they're
looking for a little more traction add a
zero and they're probably eyes would
open up exactly so up until now we've
raised about four hundred thousand from
the incubator slash accelerator and then
over the last year we focused our growth
we've three accident great almost four
accident so we're in a good place and I
read your wonderful book oh thanks it's
a really good book thank you um and so
now I'm thinking for the seed round
instead of going to the VCS why don't we
do just angels yeah and so and here's my
thing
did you happen to see an article today
in fortune by Emma hinge no Hinchliffe
okay
well it just says something that it's
been said many times but that women lead
female focused female led startups get
like 2% of VC money okay and I'm not a
whiner I'm that's fine I'm resilient but
if I'm going at Angel's is it a good
idea and should I look at angels that
will help me get to the next level if
I'm aiming for a unicorn business which
I have okay so if you're aiming for a
unicorn business and you're trying to
get past what you believe are systemic
challenges for people in this system
there is one hack around
so instead of debating are women treated
differently or not obviously they are
and to what extent all that matters is
that you have a chart that goes up into
the right when there is a chart that
goes up into the right people quickly
forget about gender and race even if
it's subconscious in my experience and
this is the this is me mansplaining and
whites planning insists white males
planning but I have seen minority women
with up and to the right black women
Asian women then up into the white right
chart and close funding you now have the
up into the right chart if you can show
that you're in control of that chart and
you know how to move it intelligently
now not perfectly but intelligently if
we spend X we get back Y you know we are
CAC typically lands here and we know how
to do retargeting and we know who our
customer is and our customers are viral
in this way when you start to show that
ability then people will look at the
organization I think differently you
also have been around for a while that
would be a bigger issue than being a
female founder or a founder of color in
my experience the being around for a
while becomes a real Scarlet Letter
if I'm using that analogy correctly and
that people will say oh it's been around
for four years and it's not a unicorn it
hasn't grown okay there must be some
fundamental flaw that's actually a
really bad way to think as an investor
so people were investors there it might
be the founder was just kind of getting
their legs under them figuring out what
they want to do and then maybe at some
way they start to feel emboldened
because they figured it out so sometimes
people get lost in the desert and then
all of a sudden they're like oh wait a
second I found an oasis oh my god I
found oil and now I'm rich right like so
I kind of look at your experience very
much like that which is hey you went out
to the desert and you starved and it was
brutal and you didn't accomplish as much
as you wanted to and then all of a
sudden you found this oasis you dug you
found oil you found diamonds or antiques
whatever it is and then you can go to
with that so I think that's the key is
to go to them and say you know we we
built what would be best described as a
lifestyle
and then here is the moment that it
changed what was the cause of that
tripling quadrupling of the revenue was
there some moment or some exact thing
that you can point to and say we
discovered this well I would say that up
until this last year our focus wasn't on
growth we had a limited budget and if we
were to grow in that way it would just
bankrupt us right off the bat so when
you have four hundred thousand dollars
total in investment for us to throw it
at customer acquisition was not a good
idea we were just our burn rate was just
move so we got our product market fit as
far as our customers being super happy
we felt like we had a product that
people stayed with right we had to solve
retention basalt before it broke yeah
you don't want to dump a bunch of water
into a leaky bucket you feel like you
solve the leaky bucket issue we got
product Mori fit what does the product
cost now and do people pay by year a
month they pay monthly $39 a month is
the average can they buy a year for 250
they can they do they are you market
that we don't market that just right now
there's a degree here it's like
basically 20% off but you you're right
in the bulb okay great yeah so I think
that's something to think about
it's $2.99 it's uh it's $25 a month when
billed annually and presenting that
first because that gives you cash flow
right and I would test that immediately
because that could also be a changer
where if you start getting a third and
then 40% and then 50% and then
eventually the majority to pay in a year
consumers when they see that calm is $60
it's like you know it's $8 a month or 60
when billed annually I think a large
percentage I don't know the percentage
off the top of my head but I think a
large percentage do that and I saw that
with also with fit bod another
accelerator company and musician a bunch
of these are saying when billed annually
I would do that now you got cash flow
coming in so I think that's a good story
to tell investors and be cognizant to
the fact that when you go out to raise
this money it's going to be a three to
six month process and they're going to
be looking at your growth each week
during it so when you fire off this
you're gonna have to serve two masters
one you're gonna have to spend half your
time fundraising and the other half
you're gonna have to plot out weekly
growth and just say over the next call
it 20 weeks we're gonna spend this
amount and grow this amount every week
and you're gonna have to go to your
partners and team members and say I need
you to hit these exact numbers of growth
you could be off a little bit but you
know if this week we have a thousand
dollars or actually in your case like
we're at five thousand a week or
something next week I want to have
exactly five percent growth so I want it
to be five thousand two hundred fifty
dollars in you know mor or whatever it
is and just start that trail now they
could easily hit it by creating this
when billed annually number but if it's
going up into the right every email cuz
I got your email recently on the update
and you didn't have any of the revenue
or charts and I was like where's the
chart because if it is going up and like
buried like halfway down your thing
there was some indication that things
were working out but people are busy
you're up against a lot of startups lead
with the weekly chart you know and have
the weekly the monthly in the quarterly
chart now of a sudden people gonna look
at and go oh chill from Rush ticks I
remember her yeah
oh she figured out I haven't pursued
angels yet though that's my so I'm
interested to know which are the ones
that I I mean obviously you're any any
investor who sees a chart going up and
to the right is gonna take the meeting
that's the thing that founders have to
understand it's very easy to get caught
up in you know the unfairness of the
world or how difficult it is or people
want to grow too fast and unhealthy
there's a lot of like anti capitalism
going around right now at this very
moment in 2019 Elizabeth Warren wants to
tax everybody like whatever two or three
percent on their ultra wealth you know
Cortez I forgot her name she wants to do
Alexandra wants to do she thinks it's
immoral to be a billionaire I don't for
the record I think it's immoral to be a
billionaire I think it's super moral I'm
really working hard to get there but
anyway you're in this like anti
capitalist society in the public sphere
but in private and in what we do
everybody's still pretty much focused on
the same thing getting rich and being
powerful and if you can focus just on
two things
building the
world-class product that people don't
want to unsubscribe for him and then
growth you could invest the growth
dollars into your team and the product
which then makes it spread which then
get you more money and that money gets
reinvested in the product and all of a
sudden you get the flywheel going you're
on the cusp of getting that flywheel
growing you have to block out all other
noise and get that flywheel going once
that flywheel is going it's very hard to
stop these businesses they just grow and
so congratulations on that can I count
you in on the next round okay so for us
to do continued bridge financing or
whatever if it's a new round I would
want to see you have half of the round
lined up before I get involved so what
happens with me a lot is people know I
get really enthusiastic and I want I
believe in founders you know how I am
and I'm just like yeah let's go what
I've had to do is have a little
discipline after maybe one or two
investments in a company which we did we
want to see you have the ability to
clear market with other investors and
then come back to us and say this
investor who's a known quantity is
putting in 250 we have 250 left how much
do you want that's how you got to go
back to your existing investors and then
you have power
I did that with inside.com I recently
was able to raise around over 2 million
dollars I said I'm putting in $250,000
and here's where I think the business is
going and I had other investors and I
went back to her existing investors in a
couple of them who had invested 10 years
ago we're like yeah I'll take my pro
rata but I don't want to go back to the
existing investors like hey keep
bridging me keep bridging me but you
should tell existing investors as Jason
said he's interested in coming in if we
can get half the round filled so he's
soft circled that's like and so I don't
want you going out there using me as
Jason's the anchor of the round use me
as like the soft circle indicate yeah oh
you haven't tell yeah so the syndicate
now the stakes are a little bit higher
since when you went through back in the
day we would do companies you know they
had a pre product market fit but now
you're up against companies that have a
little bit more traction and have
control back growth so typically they
have six months of continuous growth
that they've controlled you might have
three or four months right now we
probably have about one more two more
months of proving it because I've
trained our syndicate at the syndicate
calm to be very focused on investing in
companies
don't have leaky buckets and have
control of their growth and they're
gonna ask really hard questions and
they're very savvy so it's possible but
you're now we usually have about ten
companies lined up to do the syndicate
and what we do is we monitor all of them
and we have them deploy based on how
much of the round is closed and what
their growth is and how much money
they're making those two factors so when
people come to us and say hey the rounds
closed we've got 750 of a million is
only 250 left we have to move quickly
and then sometimes the growth is so
spectacular we say we'll do the entire
round so we've done that twice where I
said to somebody you want $800,000 we'll
put in a hundred from our fund and we'll
try and syndicated all 700 then you go
out and do other funding but that's only
if they have spectacular growth which is
usually doubling every three months or
tripling so when people have that which
is you know about 5% of our sorrows will
show that we will preemptively finance
them so those are the two hacks all
right all right well done Joe great to
see you
[Music]